I'm told that your grandmother has
trouble with your character's name is
that right bless haha I love my hands so
much so whenever she asked me what my
carats is cool because she tells her
friends at like the hairdresser's or
whatever just like what she called again
and I'm like Miss Sunday and she's like
Miss Sunday and I'm like yes Nana it's
Miss Sunday so she will be forever Miss
Sunday yeah she just thinks that name
did your for example like say to jerm
when you did a nude scene for the show
did like family like your mom did your
mom have a hard time with that or she
cool with it uh I mean I'm her baby girl
of course she's gonna be a bit weirded
out by that but she's really supportive
I think she enjoyed the scene
essentially it was a lovely scene and I
think she appreciated the story of it
but I've seen I mean who wants to see
their doors for Nathan I'm telling ya
Liam any chance you're going to end up
doing a nude scene
[Music]
[Applause]
don't get me wrong I'm all for gender
equality but if you had the choice
between seeing that beautiful lady over
there's us and Davos Seaworth Harry as
crikey leave you've actually thought
about spin-off ideas for Davos is that
right yeah I can officially announce it
today actually more this is great it's a
straight straight from HBO the spin-off
is going to be called better called
Davos
[Applause]
you